this week will be a bit different i will
show you why and how I don't goat let me
show you what sources I use in order to
learn to code and how r use them the
first one is google so i use it for any
kind of inquiry if I want to get
additional information in order to learn
other services freak out camp and you
can check under your map here what you
can learn with them and this is one of
the best resources I have ever met and
when learning to code the big class is
the community behind it and the big
class is also the fact that it's already
organized so you don't have to what to
do next but you can simply follow the
map and learn to code code school calm
are here you get a lot of first courses
for front-end developers and and part of
them is also for free codecademy calm
another website that i use great source
of knowledge and practical exercises for
those who learn in front end development
and but not only also you can learn Ruby
on Rails java and all that stuff here i
use it together with the rest of the
resources which part of the materials
that is really for free and you just
only pay for some extras another
resource that i use is your udacity.com
i haven't been using it recently but I
was starting with it they got a great
courses and also the low degree programs
none of the great problems are the paid
versions and also free courses the thing
is that you have to look through the
catalog and you can really find a lot of
useful stuff when you learn this is the
great tool that I'm using very very
often
it's Linda calm lynda.com has a variety
of courses from various fields and then
the Bitcoin will find a huge library of
courses and a lot of them are from
design a lot of them are from
development both back-end and front-end
its sky standard when we talk about
online courses and they get a quite nice
prices especially if you pay annually
and they can also try on a free trial if
you want to test them and I use them a
lot and I really like the quality of the
courses they have and the only minors is
that there's no community behind it and
it's quite passive but it's like another
source after Google and stack overflow
to do you know to look for some kind of
knowledge that you really need for your
project code pen copy layer is a very
practical way of learning to go so very
family-like something I said you know
look at the cone house built so it's
another way of learning very very
practical one it's for free and you can
also host earlier projects one more a
very useful resource is a death tips dev
tips is the channel and by travelers and
if you haven't seen his channel and hard
suggest starting with playlist where you
have a lot of awesome courses and of
course later you can search for videos
by keywords etc it's really great
whenever I find any great channel and
they definitely provide great content I
simply subscribe to it and then come
back to it and follow them these are
just a few resources that i use in order
to learn to code this is the article i
publish on medium and when you have
various resources so and you can visit
them on your own is that i presented
before other ones that I use most often
if you want to have a look at others
please have a look at this article you
will find the link to it in the video
description below he part of the mega
wasn't on
but learning to close and being a
freelancer in as possible which is
really really awesome traveling and why
I came teaches you how to deliver on
time how to push your boundaries and how
to be more productive going to Madrid I
also use these kilometers to sightsee a
bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the great thing about 80 and learning
how to code is that you really can work
remotely as a result you can sightsee
and have a lot a lot of places to visit
in the world so if it's amazing how you
can connect it working as a developer
and being a freelancer and working in
multi gives you a lot a lot of freedom
so when you are thinking about changing
your job or if you are a developer
already for a designer and one last
sight see up in the world and changeable
I've some people
and you want to choose that place you
live not that that that the wax and the
office is you start working both he and
decide about your life and coding is one
of the things that allows you to do sir
so if you are wondering how to do it how
to logical heavily and the resources
that I started using and the live alive
and use each day
[Music]
this week but I invented just only
updates on my portfolio page the rest of
the week I was focused on the client's
project which was about design next week
I'm going to have vacation so I wanna be
here but I'm coming back in two weeks
time it doesn't mean that I want
anything from code I will simply report
it a bit later so if you haven't
subscribed the ass please subscribe you
a gap to know when I post the next video
in the meantime you keep on doing keep
on learning and see you in two weeks on
you
[Music]